well of course it was a horrible
experience we'd had a wonderful morning
we'd had a breakfast and Fort Worth we'd
landed in dallas son broke out about
noon we were in a parade motorcade down
through the main part of town the crowds
were extremely enthusiastic warm excited
exuberant and just after we turned off a
main street and Eddie turned around and
said to the president mr. president you
can't say Dallas doesn't love you now
and he said no you can't we turned on
Elm Street to go under the overpass and
I heard this sound that I thought was a
rifle shot I turned to look over my
right shoulder because that's where the
sound came from to see if I could see
anything I didn't and I was in the
process of turning to look over my left
shoulder when I felt an impact is if
someone hit me with a closed fist right
in the middle of my back the force was
strong enough for it knocked me over and
I I saw that I was covered with blood so
frankly I thought I had been fatally hit
my wife pulled me down in her lap she
was seated in the jump seat on my left
and I was seated on the jump seat
directly from the president she pulled
me down into her lap at about that time
I heard another shot about that loud
smack and my eyes were open I was
cautious and I saw thee that blue velour
interior of this presidential limousine
covered with blood and brain tissue and
I knew that the president had been
fatally hit I knew it was the present
because ms kennedy said she just
screamed my god I've got his brains in
my hand you know it couldn't be a more
horrible
periods now was there conspiracy I don't
know I was there but I was taken
immediately to the hospital I didn't
know that Oswald had been apprehended
and killed because I was still out from
the operation and I wouldn't really
conscious of what was happening until
monday morning and when I woke up enough
to watch the funeral procession in
Washington so if I have all had a
conspirator or working with him he's
never been identified a lot of strange
things happened surrounding the
assassination that there's no no good
explanation for this gives rise to all
the suspicions and and what's your
personal analysis of the Warren
Commission basically the Warren
Commission I think did a good job I
think they probably overlook some things
that they they could have gone into I
think the autopsy the whole autopsy
matter was badly handled I think the
research on the president's body was not
well done but this wasn't the request of
the the Kennedy family and I think the
Warren Commission was trying to be as
sympathetic toward the family as they
could but I had a great deal of
confidence in the Warren Commission and
then I personally knew every member on
the Warren Commission and it's
inconceivable to me that men like Chief
Justice Earl Warren present later prior
to Gerald Ford Richard Russell John
Sherman Cooper John J McCloy distinguish
New York a lawyer that people like that
would be a party to any kind of a
cover-up I don't believe that I don't
believe it at all
I know you've talked a lot about it but
you said you were in the motorcade in
Dallas in 63 I was i I was setting up a
staff bus behind four or five quarts
behind the president's card the vice
president's car and I heard this
rat-a-tat-tat of what we thought was
somebody throwing a firecracker in the
crowd and suddenly you were at Parkland
Hospital walking pastor a they entered
past that into the emergency room the
the the car with the blood and mrs.
Kennedy's pink a coat still lying there
where she had leaned across her husband
to try to help him and it was a tragic
tragic day what did you do I was taken
to Air Force One we were all as soon as
president kennedy died we were twist and
I in a police car I was to Air Force One
I got on the plane and across Dallas
somehow some spirit helps you know
you've got to do something and what I
could do because I was the only writer
alone was too i knew that my all my
intuition says the reporter was that
that he would be asked something when he
got to Bergstrom and so I in Washington
yes and not Bergstrom the Andrews Air
Force Base and I block printed out those
58 words that he used this is a sad time
for all people and ending up I asked
your help and gods and I headed it when
Bill Moyers took a helicopter he and I
handed it to him and he showed that the
President and he liked it and he used it
and but I can't take any credit from
those words I mean they were handed to
me and I just
I'm grateful I was there to have that
small role but I guess they're the most
important words I've ever written but
I've written lots of others we did were
you present at the swearing-in yes
pressed against the back wall my you
felt so awful you felt so you want to
shrink from the scene almost that was my
feeling and we were all called into that
cabin and we you know it was you were
jolted I was very conscious that this
had happened in Texas all of us were it
was made things tougher and then I flew
back with them and as we got off the
plane on the welder helicopter on the
steps on the lawn of the White House the
president said go with Lady Bird and
help her all you can well you know I was
on a trip to Japan when President
Kennedy was assassinated I was with six
members of his cabinet going to a an
economic conference in Tokyo and
although I hadn't been sent to
participate in the economic conference I
was sent because President Kennedy
wanted me to organize his visit there in
February of 1964 he would have been the
first united states president to visit
japan since the end of World War two but
we were about two hours out of Honolulu
where we had spent the night when the
word came that he'd been shot and then
the word came that he had been killed
and we got back to the white house at
about two o'clock the next morning it
was a very I mean it was just about the
time that John Kennedy's body was
brought back to the White House there
was a prayer session in the East Room
Jackie came up to me and said you know
what a day you've had why don't you
sleep here tonight I'd never slept the
way out so I did sleep in the White
House although I didn't go to bed till
about five o'clock in the morning and
then of course this dramatic phone call
which came at seven in the morning phone
operator saying mr. Salinger the
president wants to speak to you and all
of a sudden going into my brain I've had
a nightmare
and then of course I hear this voice
pierdas Linden but yes I went in the
White i was in the Oval Office a lot
after JFK was assassinated because I
remained as the press secretary to
Lyndon Johnson for about four months I
came to the White House on November 22nd
1963 I was in the motorcade in Dallas
when on that day occurred that senseless
act
of mindless malice
and I was ordered aboard Air Force One
by the new president he told me wanted
me on his staff I didn't even know what
that meant and he told me I was flying
back to Washington with him I called my
wife told her I was on Air Force One and
I never returned home and that will be
27 years ago on November 22nd this year
so it was a day of cataclysmic changes
in the lives of individuals like myself
and in the life of the nation it's a day
almost every moment of which is seared
in my brain like a branding iron and no
American over the age of 10 forgets
where he was or she was on that day it
was it was to me the singular historical
event of the 20th century the murder of
a young presidents laying in the streets
of Dallas a nightmare an absolute
nightmare and and yet tell you what it
taught me taught me a couple of lessons
one everybody is replaceable
when I hear anybody in public life or in
a corporation or as I'm I said well this
company or this state or this business
can't do without you it can life will go
on number two it taught me that while
the world light and the White House may
flicker the light in the White House
never never never goes out the
constitutional bindings that hold this
nation together stronger than any person
or group and the assassination of a
president a war a depression plague
pestilence all of these shatter against
this shield of the Constitution and it's
very comforting to know that even in the
time of the most terrifying and
terrorizing disaster the country goes on